in this video we'll talk about Von
gerk's disease
this is a glycogen storage disorder and
the major Gene that is mutated here is
g6p Gene which is essential for glucose
6-phosphatase enzyme
so as the name suggests in this
particular disease the glycogen
metabolism is messed up and that leads
to many consequences
so in the glycogen breakdown process one
of the key step is to convert the
glucose 6-phosphate into glucose and
that is triggered by the enzyme glucose
6-phosphatase and due to a mutation in
the gene that produced this particular
enzyme this disease lead to a faulty
metabolism
so the signs and symptoms of this
particular disease appears at around
three to four months of age and it
generally affects the kidney the liver
and the intestines
so overall there are hyper hypoglycemia
and there can be also scissors observed
in these babies so the clinical
presentation is kind of
defined by overall abdominal distension
patients can very often face
hypoglycemic seizure or coma Global
muscle weakness and dystonia in the
muscle
and then sometimes it has been found
that there are weight loss overall
reduction in bone month bone bone mass
grip strength Etc
now the diagnosis is dependent on
detection of the glucose 6 phosphatase
activity from a liver biopsy so a
portion of the liver is taken up it can
be immunostained or it can be stained
for the presence of glycogen
so also there are genetic kind of
detection system where the G6 species
Gene is basically looked at Via
sequencing methods and looked for
mutations but this is more expensive
anyway in wondering's disease one of the
prominent feature is too much
accumulation of glycogen in the liver
cells and that can be observed from the
liver biopsy
now the in order to understand the
overall mechanism of this particular
disease progression we have to
understand the glycogen breakdown
pathway so the glycogen breakdown
pathway is as follows so there are
series of enzyme that is triggering the
breakdown of the branched glycogen into
simple glucose and each of these enzymes
can be faulty and lead to several
glycogen storage disorder one such of
glycogen storage disorder is basically
Von gerk's disease in this case the
glucose 6-phosphatase enzyme is actually
affected in other disease known as
Cory's disease Hearts disease different
other enzymes are affected you can get a
detailed video on the eye button
anyway glycogen storage disorder can be
subclassified into many categories type
0 type 1 type 1B type 2 type 3 Type 4
and so and so forth but glycogen the Von
garage disease is actually type 1A
glycogen storage disorder and it
generally affects as mentioned before
liver kidneys and the intestine
so the enlargement of liver hepatomegaly
is pretty prominent in these patients
enlargent or enlargement of the kidney
nephromegaly is also prominent
other than that biomarkers like elevated
lactate levels elevated uric acid levels
and elevated triglyceride levels or
dyslipidemia is pretty much prominent
for these patients but you must be
wondering that why these kind of things
are happening
so let me explain that angle
but before that let me tell you glycogen
is like a fixed deposit for glucose so
whenever you need glucose glycogen can
be broken down and glucose can be
provided so generally glucose can be
stored as glycogen via the process of
glycogenesis and the opposite process
glycogenolysis breaks down glycogen and
give rise to glucose and this is very
relevant when our body is undergoing
fasting so we don't have glucose from
external source so obviously the
existing glycogen present in the liver
has to be broken down to give the brain
necessary energy to perform well in that
particular fasting stage and if glucose
is not that much present then it might
lead to a hypoglycemia-like situation
which is detrimental for the brain so
all of these gsds are characterized by
faulty enzymes in the glycogen pathway
generally that affects the organs which
has glycogen storage like liver and the
muscles
so the most important enzymes for any
GSD would include these ones are among
them for one Garrix disease glucose 6
phosphatase is the key enzyme
for Cody's disease macardles and hers
disease other enzymes are responsible so
in this case we can understand how a
different metabolic pathways are
affected so one of the most important
pathway is the
glycogenolysis is disrupted that is why
majority of the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate can either go to the normal
glycolysis pathway or eventually it can
form triglyceride via glycerol
3-phosphate now too much of acetyl COA
is produced in this case where that
acetyl COA would go eventually that
acetylic wave would be utilized in fatty
acid biosynthesis or cholesterol
biosynthesis so obviously we can see on
the right hand side of the screen there
are too much of triglyceride Genesis
cholesterol and fatty acid biosynthesis
that means a hyperlipidemia or
dyslipidemic situation would be created
in this disease
now lactate can be generated from the
pyruvate in this case so obviously when
you have too much of glucose
6-phosphatase phosphate then it would be
generating pyruvate and that pyruvate
would create too much of lactate
creating lactic acidemia there are many
other situations like ah
hyperuremia hyper alaninemia so all of
these can also occur in this disease so
anyway the treatment option includes
dietary modifications and supportive
care so you know in this case glycogen
can be broken down so obviously it has
to be ensured that the babies are not
undergoing fasting for very long time it
has to be ensured that they are eating
properly and frequently
and in their meal there is substantial
amount of carbohydrate which can be
useful for their uh generation of energy
so the clinical Corner would give you
some idea about these disease so one of
the prominent feature is cutaneous
xanthoma that means kind of like a fatty
patch deposition on underneath the skin
this is very common for triglyceride
hypertriglyceridemia as well so just
because you have cutaneous anthemat that
doesn't mean that you might have a GST
another features include Apple chicks
within the with thin extremities
now all these symptoms might be present
in a baby another thing is like the very
uh
protuberant abdomen because there is a
enlargement of the liver and also the
kidney that's why due to hepatine
rhenomegali there is a huge distension
of the stomach that is another prominent
feature in this disease
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can get more notes and flash cards
in our Facebook page and Instagram page
support our Channel using super thanks
see you in next video